brandon
is with us in phoenix arizona hi brandon
welcome to the dave ramsey show
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve sir how can we help
well i i'm 35 years old i have about 180
000 uh saved up i have about 60 000
in uh credit card debt and i owe about
90 000
on my my mortgage with 10 years left on
the loan so
at the end of the year here i'm trying
to decide if i
should pay off my credit card debt and
the mortgage
and then start uh venturing into some
investment properties
or pay off the credit card debt and use
the remaining 120 000 to start investing
in some uh
properties yeah a really good question
way to go you've done real well
yeah congratulations thank you uh uh i'm
just i'm gonna start off on this one
dave though
i'm not liking the credit card debt so
that's the very first thing i'm
attacking right now
i'm paying that off when i hang up the
phone with this
yeah you know and then from there i'm
gonna go ahead and set aside some more
money make sure i have enough at least
three to six months in my savings then
you know i will be looking into the
mortgage before i look into rental
properties
so brandon when i was 28 years old i
lost everything because i was buying
investment real estate
on uh nothing down and 90 day notes and
the bank called our notes and
i had about three million dollars worth
of debt and about four million dollars
worth of real estate
so i had a million dollars worth of
equity that i lost um
due to being stupid uh that process put
me
that that pain put me on a journey
to learn how wealthy people become
wealthy and keep wealth
not what someone's opinion is or theory
is and not someone that wrote a book
once
but people that really have done it what
did they do
people with old hair or people old
people with gray hair
and money i've been young and rich i
didn't want his
opinion he was stupid okay
so i started talking to old rich people
and i found this thing called common
sense and then
for 30 years we've talked to people as a
result and sharon my wife and i made the
decision
that the closest way to financial peace
and wealth is no debt
because no debt works beautifully when
times are good because you're making
money hand over fist on everything
that's an investment
because you don't have any payments on
the rentals and
no debt works great if something like a
pandemic happens or a 2008 happens and
everything turns down
and so you know consequently right now
we're sitting on a pile of cash and a
pile of paid for real estate
a pandemic hits we feel like the third
pig the
one that built the brick house and the
wolf huffed and he puffed and it did no
good
i mean we're the pandemics out there
blowing smoke all around us
and we're just watching our some of our
friends and our people we love suffer
but financially we've not suffered
because we were ready for a storm and
when times are good
we make more money because we don't have
payments and so
then that was confirmed in the data
points
of coaching wealthy people for the next
30 years
and in the study we did for chris
hogan's book
where we studied ten thousand
millionaires the vast majority of those
ten thousand millionaires
became wealthy by being allergic to debt
and uh and then they just were very
careful
and very um intentional about investing
so if all of that to say if i woke up in
your shoes
i think you've done a wonderful job you
know accumulating some money
i'm with anthony i would pay off your
credit cards today
i would also look in the mirror and ask
how in the crap i got fifty thousand
dollars in credit card debt
and make sure that doesn't happen again
because that's got stupid written all
over it
and i'd chop up those stupid cards and
be done with them forever
then as soon as i did that i'd write a
check and pay off your house
if i did my math right you said you had
uh
90 and 50. did i did i remember that
right
uh 60 and about 90. okay it was 150
out of your 180 so you have 30 000 left
after you pay off both things
that's your emergency fund and what's
your income
uh 120 a year awesome now you have not a
bill in the world
and so you ought to be able to save
enough to pay cash for your first rental
in 18 months
yeah and then pay save cash save and pay
cash
and by the way every time you buy a
rental with cash they make money
you know the first one's hard the second
one's easier the third one's even easier
the sixth one will buy the seventh one
yeah it starts snowballing and that's
what i've done that's how i ended up
with several hundred million dollars
worth of real estate
uh we pay cash for everything i'm
sitting at a 200 000
square foot 70 million dollar building
that we paid cash for
and i'm not bragging i'm just telling
you the stuff i'm teaching you dude
it works because i haven't done anything
that was any trickery
that i don't teach you guys to do now i
made more money than a lot of people
yeah but i didn't do all this off income
i did it off of living these principles
yes
so that's what i would do if i woke up
in your shoes the shortest distance
between
you and the 45 year old with 10 or 20
million
worth of paid for real estate is the
path i just gave you
what do you think man i love it dave i
love it i love how you're teaching
i get straight to the answer you just
take us through a whole story dave
well we forget to do that sometimes
because we just go oh the answer is this
yeah
because we know the answer yes and you
know the reason you know the answer of
you know how not to misbehave talking to
a young man on another call
is you did misbehave yes you know the
way i learned about not going broke is i
went broke yeah you know
so you know my pastor used to say a man
with an experience is not the mercy of a
man with an opinion
so you know you can't talk to anthony
o'neil about how
positive the student loans are because
they screwed up your life they screwed
up my life tremendously not just that
but even credit cards i'm thinking the
same thing like how did you even get the
50 000 how did you get the 5
000 but then when i sit there and ask
that question i'm like well i did it
yeah so i know how he did it yeah you
know but um
yeah but you need to address that
because it'll grow back yes sir
if you don't if you don't pull that
dandelion out by the roots it'll grow
back and it'll bring three friends
yeah and you know what's so funny today
when i'm out there on the road some of
my close friends but all right let's be
real
did dave really you know build that big
old building cash
there's just no way and i'm like yeah i
said believe it or not
dave practiced those principles probably
10 times more than the average person
how do you do that well
first you get the money right sell steve
martin's line
steve martin a comedian he had his whole
routine how to become
a millionaire first thing was first
you get a million dollars that's like
yeah
that's good i like that yeah that's how
you do it i mean you got to scrape the
money together and the truth is
that when we bought the 10 million
dollar land under it
it took our breath away yes and the
stomach was in the throat
we built the building the first 25
million out of pocket was
unbelievable the first time i bought a 5
million building my mind was blown
the first time i bought 100 of the 50
000 rental house my mind was blown
the first time you do it you're just
like oh my god that just happened yeah
but then every time you do it it's got
that much more income associated with it
to do the next one
so we start building the second one next
door it's a lot easier a lot easier been
there done that
and we've got the extra income now to do
it with and now we're building a
conference center up on top of the hill
easier yet
you know it's going to be even easier
but it's the same thing you know the
first time you do something
and you strain and you barely get there
we bought that other building the
financial piece plaza we were in
yep and i paid 5 million for it i had
option on it for five
years i was renting it saved and scraped
got the nickels out of the couch
by the time i closed on it at 5 million
it was worth 12.
so i mean but i paid cash for it as an
option and i didn't finance
it and i didn't borrow money and believe
me i was tempted because it's worth 12
yeah if i don't exercise that option i'm
walking away from a 7 million
equity yes so whether you don't have to
put a lot of zeros on for it to make
sense
my point is is we really do this stuff
and it really does it went from 5
million
up to the 70 million building and what
what i love about your story dave that
has taught me a lot is the key thing
for you was discipline and patience it's
taken a while i'm old
but i mean i just watched you i mean you
bought the land you set on this land for
years
before you started building wait wait
another money and i'm like wow and to
see where we are today because you are
patient
and you stuck to what you teach that's
why we during covet
were able to still operate when other
businesses closed because we didn't have
any debt
you know the weird thing is is that you
look back and you go man that's 20 years
ago
and i got that went really fast yep
because it does go really fast yes sir
so whether you do it right or whether
you do it wrong it still goes really
fast yes sir
this is the dave ramsey show